den klimawandel stoppen die ungleichheit
verringern und neuen wohlstand für alle
in diesem land schaffen dafür braucht es
eine klima regierung und die gibt es nur
mit grün die aussprache hat klar gemacht
die partei ist bis in die haarspitzen
motiviert und wird bis zur letzten
sekunde für die wahl von bündnis 90 die
grünen am abend hatte einer berbalk
einen weiteren starken auftritt und hat
auch einen dritten teil überzeugt sie
war stark faktensicher und
angriffslustig der abend hat wieder
gezeigt dass der aufbruch nötig möglich
und weber ist das wochenende hat
unterstrichen was wir derzeit im land
erleben einen spürbaren zuspruch im
rücken aus der zivilgesellschaft von
kunst und kultur wirtschaft und sport
dieses land kann so viel mehr das zeigt
sich auch bei den ergebnissen der
u18-wahl die heute veröffentlicht wurden
wir konnten erstmals bei einer
bundestagswahl
stärkste kraft bei den unter 18-jährigen
werden das freut uns und das zeigt sehr
viel hoffnung auf uns grün rot wir gehen
jetzt mit rückenwind in die letzten tage
bis zur wahl denn jetzt entscheiden
viele menschen wählen sie tatsächlich
wählen werden aus umfragen werden
wahlergebnisse bei der bundestagswahl
2017 und bei der europawahl 2009 10 ist
uns erfolgreich gelungen
in der letzten woche menschen für grün
zu überzeugen wir lagen bei den
wahlergebnissen über den letzten
umfragen das wollen wir auch dieses mal
wiederholen für starke grüne in der
nächsten bundesregierung für eine klima
regierung
von diesem erfreulichen themen komme ich
zum unerfreulichen thema dem
finanzbetrug durch comics geschäfte oder
der deutsche staat und bis zu 55
milliarden euro betrogen beim
steuerbetrug gehen dem fiskus eine
zweistellige milliardensumme pro jahr
verloren die große koalition hat in den
vergangenen jahren viel zu wenig gemacht
um diese skandale zu lösen olaf scholz
folgt dabei ständig dem motto wegducken
und verschweigen während der f endlich
transparenz ankündigt deshalb ist es
skandalös dass sich der finanzminister
so wenig für aufklärung interessiert und
nicht aktiv wird bis heute hat es das
bmf nicht geschafft eine teil
geschwärzte version des protokolls zu
liefern und hat die frist im ausschuss
wieder einmal verstreichen lassen
diese hinhaltetaktik gegenüber dem
ausschuss sie muss ein ende haben zudem
hat olaf scholz als finanzminister alle
verantwortung für das chaos bei der anti
geldwäsche behörde erfahrung und bei der
gibt und genau diese organisierte
verantwortungslosigkeit
ist aber das zentrale problem bei der
bekämpfung von geldwäsche in deutschland
das chaos bei der fa wurde nicht
abgestellt und deutschland ist weiterhin
ein geldwäsche paradies diese politische
verantwortung dafür trägt er
finanzminister olaf scholz
lassen sie mich noch ein dritter punkt
ansprechen der morddrohung plakatiert
verhöhnt unsere demokratie unserer
mitglieder aber auch mitglieder alle
anderen demokratischen parteien wurden
in diesem wahlkampf immer wieder von
rechtsextremen bedroht ein solcher
wahlkampf stil vergiftet griechische
kultur führt zur verrohung und shrek
bürgerinnen bürger ab sich frisch zu
engagieren darum ist es wichtig dass
demokratinnen und demokraten sich klar
zusammenstellen gegen demokratie feinde
und ich danke allen diejenigen das den
letzten tagen parteiübergreifend mit uns
solidarisiert haben wir haben beim
landgericht münchen einen antrag auf
einstweilige verfügung gegen den dritten
weg und seine plakate gestellt dem wurde
stattgegeben
im dritten weg ist es jetzt untersagt
plakate mit dem slogan hängt die grüne
zu veröffentlichen beziehungsweise zu
verwenden doch die demokratie feinde
provozieren weiter auf dem würzburger
war barossa platz inszenierte die
neonazi partei am samstag drei
strohpuppen die tote kanzlerkandidaten
darstellen sollen das ist
menschenverachtend
unverständlich ist agierend der
staatsanwaltschaft die keine straftat
erkennen wollte wir werden anzeige
erstatten
und ich würde mich freuen wenn union und
spd ebenfalls aktiv werden denn das ist
ein angriff auf unsere demokratie
vielen dank an michael kellner ich sehe
eine erste frage von herrn bush von
web.de und
gmx web.de schießen sie gern
vielen dank
ja keiner hat sich gerade sehr kritisch
über herrn scholz geäußert während
gestern bei dem tri ace ist ja sehr
auffällig war dass es fast sondern rot
grüne front gegen laschet gab und dass
spd und grüne sich so nahe waren ist das
eine bewusste strategische entscheidung
das jetzt mit seinem nicht sagen
lagerwahlkampf aber mit sondern wir
wissen er jetzt auch mal in die letzte
wahlkampfwoche gehen oder wie ist das zu
verstehen
nun herr busch das habe ich schon öfter
gesagt es ist ja auch so es gibt
größere programmatische überschneidung
zwischen uns und der spd gerade wenn es
um fragen sozialer gerechtigkeit wie
mindestlohn geht oder die bessere
absicherung von kindern aber es gibt
eben auch große unterschiede zur spd das
ist auch gestern abend wieder deutlich
geworden nämlich unterschiede wenn es
zum beispiel um echten klimaschutz geht
da höre ich wenig von olaf scholz und
der spd diese große koalition hat in den
letzten jahren den ausbau der
erneuerbaren abgewürgt und ehrlich
gesagt wir können die pariser klimaziele
nicht erreichen mit einem festhalten
eines kohle ausstiegs erst 2038 und da
sind die unterschiede groß und na klar
wir sind wir sind in der letzten
wahlkampfwoche und natürlich betonen wir
da auch die unterschiede gerade in
diesem bereich von klima und da wo es
die gemeinsamkeiten gibt da benennen wir
sie auch
gibt es weitere fragen
derzeit nämlich keine im chat
das scheint nicht der fall zu sein dann
wünsche ich ihnen eine wunderschöne
woche
gute letzte wahlkampfwoche auf ihrer
seite und dann sehen wir uns vermutlich
nächsten sonntag
alles gute
wünschen die grünen sich natürlich auch
selber alles gute die letzte woche meine
damen und herren sie als gab nochmal
heraufbeschworen gehört es ist die heiße
phase des wahlkampfes und da tut sich
noch eine ganze menge und wir wissen vor
allen dingen nicht was dann wirklich am
ende als ergebnis herauskommt das bleibt
spannend heute